merci la parole est à madame annie
genevard pour les républicains vous avez
la parole ramda dégoûté merci madame la
présidente monsieur le premier ministre
cela fait trois ans que votre
gouvernement s'acharne à proposer de
mauvaises réformes éducatives
petit bilan d'étape la réforme des
rythmes scolaires elle épuise les
enfants désorganise les familles et hf
de vider les caisses des communes la
mise en place des écoles supérieures du
professorat d'éducation elle ne
convainquent pas plus que les temples du
pédagogisme qu'étaient les iufm
le recrutement de 60000 personnel il
interdit toute évolution salariale des
enseignants français parmi les plus mal
payés d'europe à l'élévation de tous par
le savoir qui a qui est la seule vraie
façon de luther les inégalités vous le
préférez une hasardeuse réforme du
collège qu'il supprime ce qui marche
les classes bilangues les sections
européennes l'orge ancien l'élitisme
républicain dont beaucoup d'entre vous
sont le pur produit vous le jugée
immorale et naves c'est est-ce de lui
porter des coups
privant ainsi les élèves de ce dont vous
avez bénéficié vous même des espaces
uniques
la valse des ministres de l'éducation
trois en trois ans disent votre désarroi
et hop les enseignants qui se sentent
méprisés ils ce sont des loin de vous à
peine 2 sur 10 vous renouvellerez
aujourd'hui leur confiance vous avez
perdu la recette vous avez perdu leur
confiant estelle des parents aussi
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
entendre les enseignants qui refusent
d'abdiquer le sens même de leur métier
transmettre des savoirs allez vous
entendre les parents qui demandent une
école performante dans le paquet les
bons enseignants rester dans leur
autorité sont reconnues et valorisées et
non sans cesse d
stabilisé par des réformes bancal ça va
rendre la députée la parole et or madame
la ministre de l'éducation canal
merci madame la présidente et messieurs
les députés madame la dépouille genevard
je vous avoue que j'ai un peu de mal à
répondre à votre question parce qu'il
est tellement de choses parce que je
reprends si je reprends globalement
qu'ils étaient pour la plupart
contradictoire c'est vrai mais si je
reprends globalement c'est une critique
en règle contre la politique et du
gouvernement
alors écoutez compte tenu des retours
que nous avons sur le terrain de la
façon dont cette rentrée scolaire s'est
passé je commence par m'étonner de vos
propos non oui les enseignants sont là
oui la formation initiale des
enseignants a été remise en place je
vous rappelle qu'elle avait disparu
ineptie totale
elle a été remise en place et elle
permet à 25000 jeunes professeurs
stagiaires d'être à moitié dans le class
à moitié en formation et d'entrer plus
progressivement dans le métier pour le
grand bien des élèves
oui nous menons évidemment des réformes
logique l'éducation ça n'est pas qu'une
question de moyens d'ailleurs je crois
vous avoir déjà entendu prononcer cette
phrase c'est une question en effet de
qualité des apprentissages ces réformes
pédagogiques sont passés par quoi depuis
2012 elles sont passées par un meilleur
temps d'apprentissage c'était l'objet de
la réforme des rythmes scolaires qui
s'installe partout et je redis que grâce
à la décision du premier ministre de
pérenniser l'aide de l'état aux communes
aujourd'hui les communes ont de quoi
financer les activités périscolaires des
réformes pédagogiques ça a été en effet
nouveau programme les nouveaux
programmes de l'école maternelle
trouvez moi un seul enseignant qui
estime que les nouveaux programmes de
maternelle sont les malvenus
de fait ils sont plébiscités car ils
permettent de faire de ce temps propre
un temps à part entière de
préapprentissage pour les enfants les
nouveaux programmes à venir de l'école
primaire et du collège c'est aussi une
réforme pédagogique ambitieuse et je
regrette madame genevard que vous ayez
quitté le conseil supérieur des
programmes dans lequel vous apportiez
vos analyses et vos avis éclairé je
rappelle que c'était une instance qui
étaient tous ouverte sur la diversité
parlementaire nous allons malgré tout
finir ce rail
dans l'intérêt des élèves et
j'annoncerai les nouveaux programmes
dans quelques jours la réforme du
collège quant à elle entrera en vigueur